The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So, yesterday in
the recitation we talked a
little bit about how to debug
programs on Cell.
Today I'm going to talk a little
more about debugging
parallel programs in general and
give you some common tips
that might be helpful in
helping you track down
problems that you run into.
As you might have gotten a feel
for yesterday, debugging
parallel programs is harder
than normal sequential
programs. So in normal
sequential programs, you have
your traditional set
of bugs which
parallel programs inherit.
So that doesn't get much harder,
but then you add on
new things I can go wrong
because of parallelization.
So things like synchronization,
things like
deadlocks, things
like data races.
So you have to get
those right.
Now you have to debug your
program and figure
out how to do that.
One of the things you'll see
here is a lot of tools might
not be as good as you'd like
them to in terms of providing
you the functionality
for debugging.
Add to that that bugs in
parallel programs often just
go away if you change one
statement in your code -- you
reorder things and all of a
sudden the bug is gone.
It's kind of like those pointer
problems in C, where
you might add a word, add a
new variable somewhere and
problem's gone, or you
add a print-off and
the problem is gone.
So here it gets harder because
those things can get rid of
deadlocks, so it makes it
really hard to have an
experiment that you can repeat
and come down to where the
problem is.
So what might you want
in a debugger.
So this is a list that I've come
up with, and if you have
some ideas we'll want
to throw them out.
I'm thinking in terms of
debugging parallel program,
what I want is a visual
debugging system that really
let's me see all the processors
that I have in my
network in my multi-processor
system.
That includes actual computing
and the actual network that
they're interconnecting all the
processors that are going
to be communicating
with each other.
So I'd like to be able
to see what code is
running on each processor.
I'd like to see which edges
are being used to send
messages around.
I might want to know which
processors are blocked -- that
might help me identify
deadlock problems.
For these kinds of scenarios it
might be tricky to define
step, because there's no global
clock, you can't force
everybody to proceed
through one step.
What's one step on one processor
might be different
on another, especially
if they're not all
running the same code.
So how do you actually do that
without a global clock.
So that can get a little
bit tricky.
It likely won't help with data
races, because I'm looking at
global communication problems,
I'm looking at trying to
identify what's deadlocked
and what's not.
So if there are data races, this
kind of tool may or may
not help with that.
In general, this is
the tool that I
would build for debugging.
I looked around on the web to
see what's out there for
debugging parallel
programs, and I
found this called TotalView.
This is actually something you
have to buy, it's not free.
I don't know if they have
evaluation licenses or
licences for academic
purposes.
It kind of gets close to
some of the things
I was talking about.
You have processors that shows
your communication between
those processors, how much data
is being sent through.
This particular version uses
NPI, which we talked about in
previous lectures.
So it's sort of helpful in
being able to see the
computation, looking at
the communication, and
tracking down bugs.
But it doesn't get much
better from there.
You know, how many people have
used printouts for debugging?
It's the most popular way of
debugging, and even I still
use it for debugging
some of the Cell
programs we've been writing.
I know the TAs actually
use this is well.
Yesterday you got a hands-on
experience with GDB, and GDB
is a nice debugger, but it lacks
a lot of things that you
might want, especially for
debugging parallel programs.
You saw, for example, that you
have multiple threads, you
need to be able switch between
the threads, getting the
context right, being able to
name the variables is tricky.
So there's a lot of things
that could be improved.
There are some research
debuggers, like something
we've built as part
of the streaming
projects, StreamIt debugger.
I'll show you some screenshots
of this so you can
see what we can do.
So in the StreamIt debugger,
remember we have -- so this is
actually built in Eclipse and
you can download this off the
web as well.
You can look at your
stream graph.
Unfortunately, I couldn't get a
split join in there, much to
Bill's dismay.
So you can't see, for example,
the split join in all the
communication.
Each one of these is a filter,
and if you recall the filter
is the computational element
in your stream graph and
interconnected by channels.
So channels communicate data.
So what you see here -- well,
you might not be able to quite
see it -- actually see the
data that's being passed
through from one filter
to the other.
You can actually go in there
and change the value if you
wanted to or highlight
particular value and see how
it flows down through
the graph.
If you had a split join, then
you might be able to -- in
fact, you can do this.
You can look at each path of the
split join independently
and you can look at
it in sequence.
Because the split join has nice
semantics, it's actually
you can replicate the behavior
because of the static nature
is everything is
deterministic.
So this is very helpful.
We we did a user study two
years ago almost with
something like 30 MIT students
who use the C bugger and gave
us feedback on it.
So we gave them like 10
problems, 10 code snippets,
each of them had a bug in it,
we asked them to find it.
So a lot of them found to
debugger to be helpful in
being able to track the flow of
data and being able to see
what goes wrong.
So if you had, for example, a
division that resulted in NaN
and not a number, floating
point division you can
immediately see on a screen, so
you know exactly where to
go look for it.
Doing that would print-offs
might not be as easy.
So sometimes visual debugging
can be very nice.
Unfortunately, visual debugging
for the Cell isn't
that great.
So this is the Cell plug-in
in Eclipse.
I've mentioned just to some of
you if you want to run it you
can run it from a Playstation 3,
but if more than one of you
is running it then it
becomes unusable
because of memory issues.
You can install this on other
Linux machines and remotely
debug on the Playstation
3 hardware.
So the two remote machines can
talk through GDB ports.
I can talk to you about how to
set that up if you want to,
but it doesn't really
add anything
over E-Max, for example.
It just might look fancier than
an E-Max window or a GDB
on the command line prompt.
So this is the code
from yesterday.
These are the exercises
we asked you to do.
You can look at the
different threads.
If you have debug Java programs
in Eclipse this
should look very familiar.
You can look at the different
variables.
You still have the
naming problem.
So yesterday, remember you had
to qualify which control box
you were looking at?
Still the same kind of issue --
have to do some trickery to
find it here.
It doesn't have the nice visual
aspect of showing you
which code is running on which
SPE, and you might not be able
to find mailbox synchronization
problems.
Maybe those things will come in
the future, and the fact,
they likely will.
But a lot of that is sort
of still lacking.
So what do you do in the
meantime, In the next two
weeks as you're writing
your programs?
So I've looked around for some
tips or some talks and
lectures and what people have
done in terms of improving the
process for debugging
parallel codes.
Probably the best thing I've
found is this talk that was
given at University of Maryland
on defect patterns.
So the rest of these
slides are largely
drawn from that talk.
I'm going to identify just a few
of them to give you some
examples so you can understand
what to look for and what are
some common symptoms, what are
some common prevention
techniques.
So defect patterns, just like
the programming patterns we
talked about, are meant to help
you conjure up to write
contextual information.
You had what are things you
should look for if you're
communicating with
somebody else.
What kind of terminology do you
use so that you don't have
to explain things down
to every last detail.
At the end of this course, one
thing I'd like to do is maybe
get some feedback from each of
you as to what are some of the
problems that you ran into in
writing your programs, and how
you actually went about
debugging them, and maybe we
can come up with Cell defect
patterns, and maybe Cell
defect recipes for resolving
those defect patterns.
So, probably the worst one of
all, and the easiest one to
fix is that you have new
language features or new
language extensions that are
not well understood.
This is especially true when you
take a class of students
and they don't really know the
language, they don't know all
the tools, and you ask them to
do a project in four weeks and
you expect things to work.
So there's a lot for everybody
to pick up and understand.
So you might have inconsistent
types that you use in terms of
calling a function.
There might be alignment
issues, which some of
you have run into.
You might use the
wrong functions.
You know the functionality you
want but you just don't know
how to name it and so you might
use the wrong function.
Some of these are easy to fix
because you might get a
compile time error.
If you have mismatch in function
parameters then you
can fix that very easily.
Some defects -- you know, very
natural parallel programs
might not come up until run
time, so you might end up with
crashes or just erroneous
behavior.
I really think this is probably
the easiest one to
fix, and the prevention
technique that I would
recommend is if there's
something you're unfamiliar
about or you're not sure about
how to use something, ask.
But also, you don't need to know
all the functions that
are available in something
like the Cell language
extensions for C.
Yes, there are a lot of
functions -- you know, the
manuals, hundreds of pages,
and you can't possibly go
through it all and nobody
becomes an expert in
everything.
But understand just a few basic
concepts and features.
So, David identified a bunch
that he found useful for
writing the programs, and some
of the ones that are up on the
web page under the recipes for
this course list a few more.
And so this might help you in
just understanding how these
functions work, understanding
basic mechanisms that they
give you, and that's good
enough because it'll
help you get by.
Certainly for doing the project
under short time
constraints, you don't need to
know all the advanced features
that Cell might have. Or you can
probably just pick them up
on the fly as you need them.
So what are some more
interesting
problems that come up.
I think one that is probably
not too unfamiliar is this
space decomposition problems.
So, if you remember, space
decomposition is really
data distribution.
You have a serial program that
you want to parallelize.
And what that means if you have
to actually send data
around to different processors
so that each one knows how to
compute locally.
Here you might get things like
segmentation faults, alignment
problems, you might have index
out of range errors.
What this comes of is forgetting
to change things or
overlooking some simple things
that don't carryover from the
sequential case that
are parallel case.
So what you might want to do is
validate your distributions
and your memory partitions
correctly.
So what's an example?
So suppose you had an array
or a list of cells,
each cell has a number.
What you want to do is at each
step of the computation for
any given cell, you want add
the value to the left of it
and the value to the
right of it.
So here we have cell zero
has the value 2.
We'll assume that the n
disconnectors are first, so
this is like a circular list,
a circular buffer.
So adding the left and right
neighbor would get me, in this
case, 3 plus 1, 4.
And so on and so forth.
You want to repeat this
computation for n steps.
So this might be very common in
computations where you're
doing unit [? book ?]
communication.
So what's a straightforward
sequential implementation?
Well, you can use
two buffers --
one for the current time step,
and you do all the
calculations in that.
Then you use another buffer
for next time step.
Then you swap the two.
So the code might look
something like this.
Sequential c code, my two
buffers, here's my loop.
I write into one buffer
and then I switch
the two buffers around.
Any questions so far?
So now, what are some things
that can go wrong when you try
to parallelize this?
So how would you actually
parallelize this code?
Well, we saw in some of your
labs, for example, that you
can take a big array, split it
up in smaller chunks and
assign each chunk to one
particular processor.
So we can use that
technique here.
So each processor, we have n of
them, rather size of them,
and it's going to get some
number of elements.
So each time step, we have to
compute locally all the
communications, but then there's
some special cases
that we need to treat at
the boundaries, right.
So if I have this chunk and I
need to do my new neighbor
communication, I don't have
this particular cells.
I have to go out there
and request it.
Similarly, somebody has
to send me this
particular data item.
So there's some data exchange
that has to happen.
So in the decomposition, you
write your parallel code.
Here, each buffer is
a different size.
What you do is you have some
local, which says this is how
much of the data I'm getting,
and has a total number of
elements, besides the number
of processors.
Local essentially tells me
the size of my chunk.
I'm iterating through from zero
and local and I'm doing
essentially the same
computation.
So what's a bug in here?
Anybody see it?
Sort of giving you some hints
of things highlighted in red
or there's something wrong
with the things
highlighted in red.
There's another hint.
So this is essentially the
computations going on at every
processor, this is my buffer,
and at every step I have to do
the calculations, taking care
of the boundary edges.
Anybody want to take a stab?
Mark?
AUDIENCE: Is it that the
nextbuffer zero needs to look
at data from 1?
PROFESSOR: Next buffer
zero, right.
So what might be
a fix to that?
So the next buffer is zero.
So if this is zero then buffer
of x minus 1 plus
this points to what?
AUDIENCE: So you need to
start at 1 and iterate.
PROFESSOR: Right, exactly.
It's a local plus 1, if you
were going to do these.
So that's one bug.
The other thing is the
assumption that your data
elements might be divisible by
the number of processors that
you have. So you pick the
decomposition that might not
be symmetric across
all processors.
So it's more subtle, I think,
to keep in mind.
So that's one particular kind of
problem that might come up
on your decomposing data and
replicating among different
processors.
So you have to be careful about
what are your boundary
cases going to be and how are
you going to deal with those.
The more difficult one
is synchronization.
So synchronization is when
you're sending data from one
processor to the other and you
might end up with deadlock,
because one is trying to send,
the other's trying to send,
and neither can make progress
until the other's received.
So your program hangs, you get
non-deterministic behavior or
output, every time you run
your program you get a
different result -- that
can drive you crazy.
So some of the defects
can be very subtle.
This is probably where you'll
spend most of your time trying
to figure it out.
So one of the ways to prevent
this is to actually look at
how you're orchestrating your
communication and doing it
very carefully.
So look at, for example,
what's going on here.
So this is the same problem, and
what I'm doing is now this
is the parallel version and
I'm sending the boundary
cases, the boundary cells to
the different processors.
This is an SPMD program.
So an SPMD program has every
processor running essentially
the same code.
So this code is replicated
over n processors and
everybody's trying to
do this same thing.
So what's the problem
with this code?
We're doing send of
next buffer zero.
Here, rank essentially
just says each
processor has a rank.
So this is a way of identifying
things.
So I'm trying to send it to my
previous guy, I'm trying to
send it to the next guy, and
here I'm sending the value at
the far extreme of the buffer to
the next processor and then
to the previous processor.
Anybody see what's wrong here?
AUDIENCE: So are these
blocking things?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, imagine they're
blocking things.
AUDIENCE: Why will
that deadlock?
PROFESSOR: Right.
So this will deadlock, right.
So this will deadlock because
this processor is trying to
send here, this processor is
trying to send here, but
neither is receiving yet, so
neither makes progress.
So how would you fix
it at this point?
You might not want to use a
blocking send all the time.
So if your architecture allows
you to have different flavors
of communication, so synchronous
versus an
asynchronous, a blocking versus
non-blocking, you'll
want to avoid using constructs
that can lead you to deadlock
if you don't need to.
The other mechanism -- this was
pointed out briefly in the
talk on parallel programming
-- you want to order your
sends and receives properly.
So alternate them.
So you have a send in
one processor, a
receive in the other.
You can use that to prevent
deadlock and get the
communication patterns right.
There could be more interesting
cases that come up
if you're communicating over a
network where you might end up
with cyclic patterns leading
to loops, and that also can
create some problems for you.
The last two I'll talk about
aren't really bugs in that
they might not cause your
program to break or compute
incorrectly.
Things might work properly,
but you might not get the
actual performance that
you're expecting.
So these are performance bucks
or performance defects.
So side effects of
parallelization is often case
that you're focusing on your
parallel code and you might
ignore things that are going
on in your sequential code,
and that might lead you to,
essentially you've spent all
this time trying to parallelize
your code, but
your end result is not getting
the performance that you
expect because things
look sequential.
So what's wrong here?
So as an example, imagine that
we're doing instead of reading
data from a --
so, in the previous case I
didn't show you how we were
reading data into the different
buffers, but suppose
we were getting it from some
files, so input buffer.
So now we have an SPMD program
again, everybody's trying to
read from this buffer.
What could go wrong here?
Anybody have an idea?
So every processor is opening
the file and then it's going
to figure out how much to skip
and it'll start reading from
that location.
So everybody's reading from a
file, so that's OK, nobody's
modifying it.
But what can go wrong here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE PHRASE].
PROFESSOR: Right.
So essentially, sequentialize
your execution because reading
from the file system becomes
the bottleneck.
So you'll want to schedule input
and output carefully.
You might find that not
everybody needs to do the
input and output.
Only one processor has to do
the input and then it can
distribute it to all the
different processors.
So, in the Master/Slave model,
which a lot of you are using
for the Cell programming, the
Master can just read the data
from the input files
and distribute it
to everybody else.
So this avoids some
of the problems
with input and output.
You can have similar kinds of
problems if you're reading
from other devices.
It doesn't have to be
the file system.
So here's another one,
a little more subtle.
So you're generating data--.
Hey, Allen, what's up?
AUDIENCE: I somehow missed the
distinction between when
you're waiting for the master
to read all the dat aand
distribute it, and waiting for
the other [? processes ?] to
get through so I can read my
private data, isn't it going
to be about the same
time on this?
PROFESSOR: No.
So here, just essentially, the
Master reads the file as part
of the initialization.
Then you distribute it.
So distribution can happen
at run time.
So, the initialization you
don't care about because
hopefully that's a small
part of the code.
So this code is guarded by rank
equals Master, so only it
does this code.
Then here you might have the
command that says wait until
I've received it and then
execute, or on the cells, then
these might be the SPE create
threads that happen after
you've read the data.
So hopefully, initialization
time is not something you have
concern about too much.
So if you're generating data on
the fly or dynamically, so
here we might use the Srand
function to sort of start with
a random seeing and then
fill in the buffer
with some random data.
So what could go wrong here?
So in Srand, when you're using
a random function -- sorry,
this is the same function.
When you're using a random,
a pseudo random number
generator, you have to give it
a seed, then if everybody
starts off with the same seed,
then you might end up with the
same random number sequence.
If that's something you're
using to parallelize your
computation, you might, in
effect, end up with the same
kind of sequence on each
processor and you lose all
kinds of parallelization.
So there's some hidden
serialization issues in some
of the functions that you
might use that you
should be aware of.
The last one I'll talk about is
performance scalability defect.
So here you parallelize your
code, things look good, but
you're still not getting --
you've taken care of all your
IO issue, you're still not
getting the performance
you want.
So, why is that?
You might have -- remember your
Amdahl's law, and what
you want is an efficiency
that's linear.
Every time you add one processor
you want a straight
line curve between the number
of processors and speed up.
This should be a linear
relationship.
So you might see sublinear speed
ups, and you want to
figure out why that is.
Some of the common causes here,
and this will be the end
up focus of the next talk
is, unbalanced amount of
computation.
Remember, dynamic
load balancing
versus static load balancing.
Your work estimation might be
wrong and so you might end up
with some processors idling,
other processors
doing too much work.
So the way to prevent this is
to actually look at the work
that's being done and figure
out whether it's actually
roughly the same amount
of work everywhere.
Here you might need profiling
tools to help, and so I'm
going to talk about
this in a lot more
detail in the next lecture.
So in summary, there are lots
of different bugs that you
might come up with.
There's a few that I've
identified here, some common
things you should
look out for.
So the erroneous use of language
features understand
only a few basic concepts of the
entire language extension
set that you have. Space
decomposition, side effects
from parallelization.
Don't ignore sequential code.
Last one is trying to understand
your performance
scalability.
But there are other kinds
of bugs, like
data races, for example.
So what can you do with those?
So remember, data races you
have different concurrent
threads and they're
trying to update
the same memory location.
So depending on who gets to
write first and when you
actually do your read, you might
get a different result.
So with data race detection,
these things are actually
getting better.
There are tools out there that
will essentially generate
traces as your program
is running.
So for each thread you
instrumented and you look at
every load stored at executes.
Then what you do is you look at
the load in stores between
the difference threads and see
if there's any intersections,
any orderings that might give
you erroneous behavior.
So this is getting better, it's
getting more automated.
Intel Threadchecker
is one example.
There are others.
I really think the trend in
debugging will be towards
trace-based systems. You'll
have things like
checkpointing.
So as your program is running
you can take a snapshot of
where it is in the execution,
and then you can use that
snapshot later on to inspect
it and see what went wrong.
I think you might even have
features like replay.
In fact, some people are working
on this in research
and in industry.
So you might be able to say
uh-oh, something went wrong.
Here's my list of checkpoints,
can you replay the execution
from this particular stage
in the computation.
So it helps you focus down
in the entire lifetime of
execution on a particular
chunk where
things have gone wrong.
This is sort of a
personal dream.
I think one day we'll have the
equivalent of a TiVo for your
programs, and you can use
it for debugging.
So my program is running,
something goes wrong, I can
rewind it, I can inspect things,
do my traditional
debugging, change things maybe
even, and then start replaying
things and letting the
program execute.
In fact, we're working on things
like this here at MIT
and with collaborators
elsewhere.
So, this was a short lecture.
We'll take a break.
You can do the quizzes.
Note on the quizzes,
there are two
different kinds of questions.
They're very similar, just one
word is different, and so
you'll want to just keep that in
mind when you're discussing
it with others.
Then about 5, 10 minutes and
then we'll continue with the
rest of the talk, lecture 2.
Thanks.